so when I start from the bottom and
build a weather application from zero
starting with the database all the way
up to the end point now we only have
about 15 minutes we're gonna see if we
can get this all done in time so the
first thing we want to do is kind of
start with this example so here's a
terminal everyone like terminals is that
cool someone's like where's my GUI we'll
get there all right so what I want to do
is maybe start with a few leather
weather locations so these are all of
our regions in the US our newest region
being Los Angeles California and the
goal is I want to take these names and
get weather data now here's a problem I
can't just give these names to the
Weather Service I actually have to give
them geo coordinates ok now I have a
couple of options here I can actually
use the Maps API so the Google Cloud
Maps platform does provide a places API
that I can trade those names in and get
back some coordinate or something close
and then once I have those I can
actually send those to the weather gov
and actually get back coordinates but
here's the thing I don't have a lot of
time to write all of this code now once
you become a senior engineer I'm gonna
teach you a couple of tricks now this is
what all senior engineers do you guys
ready for the first protip now you got
to write some code now this is what we
do you do this if you haven't heard of
Stack Overflow you have no clue what's
going on all right so let's do this
Google Maps platform like this is high
quality code that you can find on this
thing man trust me
and we'll do weather and then okay let's
go over here all right how do we do this
Oh code this looks legit all right I'm
not sure who this terrence Ryan guy is
but you know now this is the Internet so
what you got to do is you got to scan
for those security vulnerabilities all
right you gotta gotta make sure this
stuff is legit hold on let's make sure
we can grab this let's see what we're
gonna do here so let's grab this code
come on I don't care about cookies
it's the internet how dangerous could it
be where's my copy and paste like why
they trying to sell me stuff I'm trying
to get my job done
come on like the hardest part of this
alright look at this ads alright we
should be in business now all right so
let's grab this so what you want to do
is you want to scan for security
vulnerabilities as you go through this
that looks legit tuck into a database
sure why not
cool let's just grab that so here's the
thing Oh Holly I should be fired this is
why we use gifts all right copy so one
thing is good programmers copy great
programmers paste all right so we got
our code now the next thing we need to
do is set up a database now I am the
world's most average DBA so for me I'm
going to use a hosted database service
and I like to keep it open source so my
favorite database is Postgres and what
I'm gonna do here listen if you're a
developer you need to set up the
database there is no shame in clicking
the button click database BAM like a pro
okay got to own it so I got this
database setup and I created a user I
actually do not know how to create a
user so I usually click this button
because I can't have to look it up all
the time so once I have the user create
it I have a little EMV file so I can use
natural tools so think I'd like about
this I can use my existing tools to do
my job so the first thing we're going to
do here is we're going to get the
environment variables for my connection
string in my environment and then we're
going to see we can connect to the
actual database and I can make sure we
don't have any tables set up so we're
starting from scratch now the next thing
I need to do is actually set up the
database schema all right so there's
some sequel list dope by the way if you
don't know sequel you should learn it
okay so P SQL and then we're just run
this create database command oh we need
to get our credentials so PG that env
and then let's do this and then come on
well we got a database schema and let's
make sure we don't have any data in
there all right we're starting from
scratch so the next thing we're going to
do is you're going to change into that
directory where we've downloaded that
production-ready code from the internet
and what we're going to do is we're
going to give it traditions ok so this
should be Cola JIT this guy is a nice
guy I'm pretty sure so I'm going to put
those credentials in my environment and
then what we want to do now is just do
something local so I build code I like
to test locally I do not develop in the
container I test things on my local
machine so here what I want to do is do
a quick build and I'm usually the new
vigo stuff so I can actually do
development work without using a go path
so for me I'm writing everything and
going and then what I want to do is just
build the application oh and it compiles
that's legit so let's try it let's see
what we can do so remember the goal is
we're gonna take locations and we want
to trade them for geo coordinates so we
can then talk to the Weather Service so
let's try that now
so we'll do weather data alright so look
at this is like science geo coordinates
ok all right and then we're getting the
weather data so if everything is legit
we should be able to do a query and we
have the weather data in our database
alright so we're in business all right
now that we've got our weather data we
need somewhere to actually run our code
and also if you have the idea of running
this command from your laptop in
production every day that's not how you
do it you might want to run this code in
a cluster somewhere so we need some
infrastructure so the next thing you do
is we need a kubernetes cluster there's
no other place better to run your code
than kubernetes marketing I've done my
job alright so so here's a kubernetes
cluster but there's something
interesting here so there's a couple of
tricks that I like to do here's my
kubernetes question one thing you can do
that's really nice in GCP you can
actually have multiple node pools so
this is the tin one 10.5 cluster I have
13 nodes here but I actually have those
no split between two different node
pools now the reason why I'm doing this
is I'm using their first general pool
for my web apps my batch jobs
long-running services but this other
node pool
I'm a big fan of envoy so you've been
hearing a lot about sto but underneath
sto this is nice reverse proxy called
envoy and I'm believe you can think
about it's like a cloud native
replacement for engine X or H a proxy it
has all the things that I need to do
things like rate limiting and timeouts
and retries but I like to actually run
envoy as my edge load balancer even in
GCPs the same load balancer I run on my
laptop so I want some parity so what I'm
doing is I'm actually running each of my
Envoy instances across these three nodes
using what we call a daemon set and then
the last thing I do to set up my
infrastructure I create a load balancer
that points to just those three machines
so if you think about it I have a
network appliance running inside of my
cluster no extra hops no IP tables
straight to Envoy then directly to my
apps so with the infrastructure in place
we can start to think about deploying
our code so let's go back to the command
line I really quickly so the next thing
I want to do is I don't want to execute
this from my machine so here's a cron
job every five minutes this is going to
kick that code off for me automatically
so my goal is just to push this con job
up but remember the price of admission
to kubernetes is a container image
here's my second trick that I like to do
I have this saying don't ship build
environments ship artifacts so when I
ship when I build my containers I
actually just build my binaries locally
upload the artifact and only have docker
packaged it in an image with the scratch
base image
alright so my image is roughly are about
seven Meg's and then watch how fast the
builds are if I do it this way so the
first I'm going to do is build that
application locally take that binary
push it up to Google cloud build and
cloud builder is going to do all the
work for me you'll notice another thing
here I don't have docker installed on my
machine I can just push my bills there
and get all my images so in just a few
seconds we'll have a container image
we're ready to go and then we can
actually use that cron job in kubernetes
we'll keep it running soku CTO applied -
f cron yeah mo all right so you'll
notice there will be no pods created
until we hit that five-minute mark but
we'll start watching just to see when
things come up so in about five minutes
you'll see the cron drive kick off and
Cooper neighs we'll keep a few of them
around just in case I need to trouble
- all right so the next thing we want to
do is when I move a little bit faster
now is I need to put an API in front of
this so we're going to do here is say
coops ETL apply - f and I have this
weather API service and then what I'm
gonna do here is just deploy that and
that's gonna be a little bit faster
because I want it right now I already
have the image on the container registry
it's going to pull it into the cluster
and it's gonna start running now here's
the next cool thing that you can do in
GK we've done a lot of work to make pods
first-class citizens inside of Google
Cloud so you'll notice here every pot
and kubernetes gets its own IP address
now the one thing that we do is we make
those ip's native using a technology we
call IP aliases and what IP aliases does
it takes all of those container IPs and
make them first-class in my bpc so my
development box is a is a VM inside of
my V PC so what I should be able to do
is actually without any port forwarding
or extra hops I should be able to make a
call to my API servers using the
container IP and look at that directly
talking to the container using a very
natural development flow where I can
work on another app why talking to apps
inside of the cluster that's pretty dope
if you didn't think so
all right so we're moving along here the
next thing we want to do is get a web
front-end again you kind of establish
some patterns here build it build a
container push it up and describe the
kubernetes what you want to do so here
we'll build our weather front-end and
then we'll do this deployment
now here's what things get a little bit
of interesting we're not gonna run one
copy we're gonna let kubernetes run
three copies across that cluster for us
now once all of this is running I have
envoy in a pre-configured IP and a DNS
address that's pointing to this
particular back in so what I'm gonna do
now is pull this up and we should be
able to hit the weather back in Oh
things are looking good let's see all
right everything seems to be working now
here's the thing I've been the solo
developer this whole time I know the
front-end talks to the API server and
the API server talks to the database but
what happens is someone else on your
team needs to check things out the nice
thing is I've been using open census so
again I don't actually have a service
match but you can adopt all these
technologies a la carte so if you want
to add tracing to your application you
can bring in tools like the open census
library that allows you to decorate your
function calls or calls between apps and
send that data to tools like Zipkin or
Jaeger in my case I'm using Google Cloud
soar going to send it's a stack driver
trace I'm gonna pop over here to the
tracing console and then we're going to
find one of those recent traces so we
can see one that just came in or roughly
around now and we'll click on it and you
can actually see the end-to-end traffic
comes in to the front-end the API and
then API returns but not before talking
to the database now here's a nice thing
if you trace this inside of your
codebase and I click show events I can
come down here and see the exact sequel
query that's being executed at that
particular hop now that gives you the
ability to actually see what's going on
and give people a lot more insight
without checking out the code all right
so we got all the patterns in place
infrastructure tracing and now we need
to think about something new now we only
have about five minutes left so we're
gonna have to simulate this it's not
when your boss shows up it's like hey we
need some new functionality can you get
it done by Friday all right so the task
is on so we have this infrastructure we
got this nice
set up and what we want to do now start
to think about something cool we can add
in we got a web front-end but that's
like so 2017 you got to have a voice
integration with your app if you want to
be cool if you can't talk to your
application you're probably doing it
wrong okay so we want to do is think
about a tool called dialogue flow you're
not going to build your own natural
language processing system from scratch
some of you are probably trying there's
a better way so we're gonna use dialogue
flow so again let's walk through the
pattern really quickly we're going to
write the application and then we're
going to build it and push it up now
remember the container image is just a
press of admission so we'll build this
up now here's the other thing you won't
be the sole developer working on this
application forever maybe there's
someone else on the team that wants to
contribute and maybe they have no
interest in writing yamo files or using
kubernetes from the command-line we've
done a lot of work to make sure that
kubernetes works well from the UI so
we'll come over here we'll go to the
kubernetes console and we can click on
workloads now notice here all the things
I did on the command line are reflected
in the gke console now if I have a new
person on the team that's not quite
familiar with kubernetes this could be
their workflow we'll click deploy and
we've done something special here we've
integrated deeply with GCP including the
Google container registry so if I click
on this I can drop down and find that
image that I just created it finds all
the right tags hit select and then it
fills out everything I need underneath
let's give this a name we'll call it the
weather assistant we have the right
labels and if I have multiple clusters I
can choose where should deploy now if
you want to see what's going on
underneath the hood you can actually
display that sweet sweet yam oh that you
love so much and then we also give you
an auto skeleton make sure you can
respond to traffic changes and we'll hit
deploy so that's gonna do all the heavy
lifting for me right through the UI and
just like that it should be deployed
we'll switch over here and we can see
the weather assistant is now ready
serving traffic now the next thing we're
going to do is make sure that we're
ready by checking the health check
so here's the DNS name that I've
assigned to this particular app we'll
hit it we see everything is ups were
'king and we can also see all my track
is flowing through Envoy I should be in
good shape all right so we only have a
few minutes left let's see if we can
pull this last piece off so I'm going to
log into the dialog flow console this is
also part of the Google cloud platform
so dialogue flow allows you to design
these voice integrations with your
application so we'll come here there's a
couple things we need to do first we
need to make sure that our users have a
good time with our application so we're
going to do is we're going to define all
this verified inputs and create a few
synonyms just in case you want to say
things like Los Angeles or Los Angeles
California USA to talk to the weather
app the next thing we're going to do is
describe their intent what does our user
want to do so here we want to have them
check the temperature now there's no way
I'm going to define everything or every
phrase our users would do so here what
I'm gonna do is give dialog flow a few
training phrases and notice how it's
automatically pulling out those regions
that match the entities that I've
described before so we're ready to go
now I want to send this to our web hub
that we just got deployed so we'll come
here we have a couple more steps
we'll go to fulfillment and and
fulfillment you'll see that I'm just
putting in that same URL that I had
earlier that's pointing to my kubernetes
stack all right
you have all kind of integrations that
you can do but this time we just want to
do the Google Earth system now this
whole time I've been using my pixel book
to do this demo and this is something
that I also think a part of the
end-to-end experience at Google so we
want to test out this now I could use
the simulator or I can actually come
down here and use my laptop now to prove
that this is real we're gonna look at
the logs for the assistant to make sure
Kelsey isn't cheating alright so coupes
ETL logs will give it that container
name and we just chained the logs here
so we can see it's listening but there's
nothing there yet so if I hit the
assistant button on my pixel book we
should be able to talk to this thing
yeah whatever
alright talk to the talk to the local
Weather Service sure here's the test
version of local weather hello Kelsey
hello
looks like you have a pretty large crowd
here
I hope the demo gods are on your side I
hope so too all right so let's give this
a go what's the current temperature in
Los Angeles California the current
temperature in Los Angeles California
USA is 82 degrees Fahrenheit thank you
okay I gotta admit that was pretty dope
[Applause]